as a young girl I was an understudy in
an Off-Broadway show alongside which pop
icon a Christina Aguilera B Britney
Spears C Lady Gaga be Britney Spears
true all right what was what was she
like did you get the meter I actually
didn't work alongside her I actually
took over from her because she went on
to do the Mickey Mouse Club so I never
met her then but I did meet her later
and she was lovely and you went yeah oh
yeah wait did Britney Spears come to
your car didn't we through a New Year's
party together together that's what it
was that's so cool you also look like
you're in the oops I Did It Again music
video in the classroom intentionally
yeah